everyone and welcome to today's live
broadcast handling of viscous liquids
basics techniques and tricks presented
by dr. Han a honkey content editor
Eppendorf AG hamburg germany
hi I'm Alexis Kraus of lab routes and
I'll be moderating for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by Eppendorf for more information on our
sponsor please visit at the NORTHCOM now
let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button once
there as many of your questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support tab found at the top-right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left to
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr. Hana hand hanky
dr. honey hanky is the content editor of
Eppendorf headquarter in Hamburg Germany
she joins Eppendorf in 2015 as
application specialist for liquid
handling right after finishing her PhD
and Medical Microbiology on the topic of
s epidermidis hip joint infections at
the University Hospital in Hamburg honey
focused on molecular biology and
genetics early during her studies of
biology at the University of Hamburg and
deepened her knowledge in food
microbiology laboratories and at Harvard
Medical School in the group of professor
Roberto Coulter
a project management course in
cooperation with Johnson & Johnson
medical Germany extended doctor dr.
Hankey skills and establishing trainings
and giving seminars for complete
biography on dr. Hankey please visit the
biography tab at the top right of your
screen
dr. Hankey you may now begin your
presentation thank you very much for the
nice introduction Alexis and hello
everyone I'm very happy to present you
today's webinar about with good liquid
and then handling in the lab
but first of all I would like to give a
brief description about viscosity and
Newtonian and non-newtonian fluids so
then I would like to point out the
influence of viscous liquids on
pipetting and describe proper pipetting
of these challenging liquids in the end
there will be a short summary
so viscous liquids generally have a slow
flow behavior deriving from a high in a
friction of molecules viscous liquids
also have a much higher density than
water the density has to be taken into
account for measuring the viscosity and
all pipetting applications there are two
characteristics of viscosity of which
both should be specified when describing
a viscous liquid the dynamic viscosity
describes the moving liquid by
considering the inertia of mass and
resistance to shearing flows the shear
stress is proportional to the gradient
of velocity velocity can also be
determined as speed so the more shear
stress is applied the faster the liquid
flows dynamic viscosity is stated in
nearly Pascal second
it measures the fluids resistance to
flow when an external force is applied
the graphic on the right shows the
definition of dynamic viscosity the blue
lines are plates and in between is a
viscous liquid if you start moving the
upper plate the liquid flows with the
plate but only in layers so the first
layer is faster than layer number two
and layer number two is faster than
layer number three you will need
constant force to keep the upper plate
moving otherwise the high enough
friction of molecules will stop the
upper plate from moving this also
explains why they could flow takes so
long with viscous liquids and the thin
layer of liquid remains to the surface
positive describes the ratio of dynamic
viscosity to the density of the fluid
kinematic viscosity is stated as square
meter per second kinematic viscosity is
the resistive flow of a fluid under the
weight of gravity two fluids that have
the same dynamic viscosity can have
different kinematic viscosity this is
because kinematic results are dependent
on the density of the fluid density is
not a factor with dynamic viscosity
the differences between the two types of
viscosity our bet dynamic viscosity is
related to the external force applied to
the non-newtonian fluids while kinematic
viscosity is the inherent viscosity of
Newtonian fluids that does not change
for the change in applied force during
this webinar we will concentrate on the
dynamic viscosity of fluids because we
talk about moving these fluids with
pipettes and dispensers therefore
dynamics are more important but I will
use Newtonian fluids as example because
they are more predictable
so the
/ to Newtonian and non-newtonian fluids
and their definitions viscous fluids can
be further categorized in two categories
Newtonian and non-newtonian fluids and
utonium fluid is easily described
because it's flow property is linear and
the viscosity is independent of shear
stress for example water
no matter how much pressure is applied
to water it's slow behavior does not
change in contrast non-newtonian fluids
react to shear stress and can be
categorized in four classes shear
thickening or thinning thixotropic and
real Patrick
let's have a closer look on these
classes
shear thickening fluids are mostly
suspensions such as Oh Blake a mixture
of cornstarch and water its viscosity
increases with shear stress and it
becomes less fluid when pressure is
applied in the moment the pressure is
released it returns to its initial state
of solidity this finally viscous liquid
can be used for experiments in school as
it is harmless and easy to prepare
she assuming fluids react the other way
around
and become more fluid when stressed
so the fluids become more fluid such as
ketchup or tomato sauce which gets more
fluid after shaking the bottle
reowww peptic fluids all social increase
of viscosity but it is time dependent
we electic fluids get less fluid over
time one shear stress is applied and it
also takes at least the same time until
it returns to its initial State
so tropic fluids reacts oppositely and
become more fluid over time when
constant shear stress is applied for
these fluids it also takes time to
return to the initial State
basically to remember she is sickening
and she assuming liquid returned to
their initial set immediately when the
shear stress is ending while real tactic
and thixotropic fluids need time to
return to the initial state but how do
we measure this cavity at all viscosity
can be measured with viscous emitters
one example shown here in the picture
this is a rotational viscometer it can
measure Newtonian and non-newtonian
fluids for measurement the fluid is
filled into a beaker and the appropriate
agitator is attached to the device this
agitator is turning and measures the
shear of low resistance in an
unspecified value with this value and a
conversion formula list
corresponding to the device the dynamic
viscosity can be determined
please excuse for this chart being in
German I simply copied it from the
operating manual of our device in the
lab but it shows the type of rotor used
on the left side the educator speed in
the first row and the coefficient for
multiplication to obtain the dynamic
viscosity so this chart you can
calculate the viscosity of the liquid
that is inside the beaker
however it is simpler to use capillary
based instruments and in some cases
these are more accurate for determining
kinematic viscosity this is usually a
question of costs which kind of is
kilometers you are using
we will now concentrate on Newtonian
fluids because their behavior is easier
to understand and more predictable than
non-newtonian fluids glycerol will be
the main example because most of us are
using it regularly in the lab for many
different applications
I would like to do to answer a question
so how do you pipette glycerol and we
have four different answers please make
your choice between one of them so the
first is I cut the pipe at tip the
second is I weigh my sample the third is
I wait a long time during expiration and
dispensing and the fourth possible
answers I use reverse piping technique
so we will wait a couple of seconds
so that you can read through the
question and the answers
and you can shoot the answer that fits s
to what you're doing in the lab
we just wait until everybody made a
choice and then
look at the resolve
so I will
we'll wait a few more seconds maybe five
to ten seconds and I think then
everybody will have made the choice how
to pipe it glycerol at the moment in the
lab
with four different answers and some of
you are still choosing their answers
whether they wait a long time or they
cut the piper tip or wheels delaying
your sample orders using a special
packaging technique for packaging
glycerol
I think that from all of you made a
choice
protect you okay so what we see here is
interesting so most of you wait a long
time doing aspiration in dispensing
which is great because we have to
because it's a very slow flow and
there's still a lot of you are weighing
the sample which is also a way to deal
with this but you always have to
calculate in the density then some of
you are also using reverse pipe between
technique which is great actually we
will talk about this a little later and
they're almost 22% still cutting the
piper tips so this is something I did do
my PhD as well I have to admit but we
will come to this a little later and
what happens when types of cattle in the
private clip okay
so don't carpeting of this because
liquids characteristic behaviors of the
liquid show some liquid always remains
in the piper tip when classic pipers are
used as you see in the image on the
right side often also air bubbles are
additionally aspirated because the
liquid has a very slow flow behavior and
when you pull out the tips before the
liquid is aspirated completely air is
suddenly sucked into the tip less liquid
is aspirated than the set volume and
pipe it in viscous liquid lead to
inaccurate typing results if the wrong
typing technique and inappropriate
typing tools are used
if you don't think about using a
multi-channel pipette for your
application the errors increase and
often each channel of the pipette
delivers different amount of viscous
liquid so any curacy multiplies when
multi-channel pipettes are used I will
give a tip for applications with
multiple samples later on but as
promised let's go over to cutting the
tip in the poll questions some of you
answered that they are cutting off the
pipette tip to a spurt of glycerol and I
know that many other people are doing
this in the lab as well so as I already
honestly said I did this as well before
getting deeper into the topic of
accurate typing techniques but when
cutting the positive inaccuracy and
imprecision increases dramatically in
this graphic you can see the inaccuracy
and imprecision of different type of
tips the one on the left is an undamaged
complete capitis used for distilled
water in accuracy and imprecision are
very low and within the acceptable error
limits when this tip is shortened by
cutting up the tip and used with water
inaccuracy increases a lot and
imprecision increases slightly now to
take it to the top glycerol is pipetted
with a cut off type of tip and as you
see in the far right on the graphic both
inaccuracy and imprecision increase
dramatically
leading to unreliable results it is
almost as bad as if one would only pour
the glass roll from the bottle into the
sample so this is what happens when
using classic pipettes a cut-off type of
tip and the wrong type gene technique
now we must take a step back and have a
look on the type of themselves the
classic pipettes most of us are using
our air-cushion pipettes the name
derives from the air inside the pipette
that is between the actual sample liquid
and the instruments typically when the
air is pushed out by pressing the top
button according to the amount of air
liquid is soaked into the pipette tip
when the button is slowly relieved as
you can see the liquid has direct
contact with the air inside the pipette
this system is widely distributed and
only suitable for aqueous solutions
since these pipettes are calibrated to
water problematic viscous liquids with a
higher density than water cannot be
pipetted accurate without a special
technique like reverse pivoting we will
discuss this technique in a minute less
sensible are positive displacement
pipette also known as stepper or
dispenser here the liquid is soaked into
a tip with an integrated piston there is
direct contact between the liquid and
the piston and there is no air cushion
this system allows the transfer of all
liquids no matter if they have a high
density or high viscosity dispenser are
more precise and more accurate than air
casual type acts with problematic
liquids
the tip of a stepper or dispenser is
filled once and then the liquid is
dispensed in multiple steps a positive
displacement pipette which works with
the same principle is used for single
inspiration and dispensing of
challenging liquids nevertheless classic
pipes can be used with a special
technique to facilitate working with
viscous fluids so you don't have to buy
a new device
so let's shortly go through the classic
packaging technique which is forward
pipetting every one of you is doing this
in the lab almost every day I guess
pushing the operation button down to the
first step aspirate in the liquid the
pushing to the second step for
dispensing including the blow out so
this is daily business and most
effective with equation solutions
buffers with a giraffe when using this
technique with viscous fluid some liquid
remains in the tips because the air
inside the pipe it is compressed against
the viscous liquid and the blow out
cannot be executed properly the slow
flow behavior of whiskers liquid
additionally hinders the liquid flow
from natural flow out the set volumes
has never dispensed accurately so let's
have a look at the second technique and
some of you already answered they are
using reverse type setting for their
viscous liquids this is the second
technique and it's beneficial for
viscous liquids the operation button is
pushed to the second stop then the set
liquid volume including the blow out
volume is aspirated but while dispensing
the operation button is only pushed down
to the first stop like this the set
volume is dispensed but the blow out
volume remains in the tip this technique
enables the piper to dispense the set
volume more accurately and the blower
foam is calculated remaining volume
if we now compare forward positive
reverse pipetting and usage of the
directive placement device when type it
in 50 micro liter of 87% glycerol we can
see that forward pipetting which is the
brown line leap to a massive variety in
results while reverse pipetting which is
the green line on top is already more
steady still the usage of a positive
displacement device leads to even more
accurate results also showing a high
steadiness and reliability in each
dispensing step positive displacement is
therefore recommended for viscous fluids
anyway I will give some more tips for
using classic pipettes in a few minutes
but first of all I would like you to
know first of all I would like to tell
you about multiple samples as I promised
in the beginning and then I will ask
another question so first of all
multiple samples um I promised to give a
tip on that if you have to overlay your
samples with glycerol for long-term
storage or oil for PCR I recommend using
a stepper or dispenser instead of the
multi-channel pipette you will be able
to expert the liquid once and then
dispense one sample after the other with
the same accuracy and precision so this
also makes your results much more
comparable depending on the volume you
need only one filling of the tip is
needed to dispense 96 times and the
complete plate is finished so you can
save time and effort by increasing their
accuracy precision and reproducibility
and I think that sounds great so now we
will go over to the next question and
since we talked a lot about positive
displacement already I would like you to
Ansel if you use positive displacement
devices for piping viscous fluids we
again we have four different answers
it's yes
no but I will consider it now sometimes
order using the sirens which is
basically also a positive displacement
device just with with not not on a
touchable tip because the tip is
integrated in that the sirens so again
we will wait a few seconds until
everybody make a choice and read through
the question
I will repeat the question once do you
use positive displacement devices for
pipes and viscous fluids already you can
answer either it yes no but I will
consider it now sometimes or I am using
a silent for the samples
so I will play some more
till you have the time to made your
choice
maybe also some of your colleagues are
with you in the lab or in front of the
computer also going to answer
okay so I think I think we are clear and
I think you can see the results now and
most of you and that that makes me
really happy so thank you very much so
you will consider now to use a positive
displacement device for viscous liquids
this is great and I think this is the
best choice the best answer you can give
some of you are already using a positive
displacement device which is also very
positive I'm also very happy you're
doing this and sometimes is also great
maybe when we finish the webinar you
will think about using it even more
often and sirens which is already also a
positive displacement device is also a
great choice and but I have to admit
with the silence it's more difficult to
get an accurate volume because you
cannot set the voluminous I mention
either the full volume or it's more or
less a guess of how much volumes you are
really about pipetting okay
so then let's go over to the part I
think you're all waiting for it's the
tips and tricks for pipetting discuss
liquids there are three questions you
have to ask first before starting to
pipe it in viscous liquids the first one
is how viscous is the liquid is it low
medium or high and we will do the
definition in the next slide the second
question is is it in utonium or
non-newtonian fluid many non-newtonian
fluids cannot be piped due to their
behavior under pressure and these
liquids must be weighed so for those of
you having this very challenging liquid
I'm sorry you must still weigh them
because they behave some very incredible
on the pressure and the third question
is what volume must be transferred so
small volumes from 1 to 1000 microliters
can be done manually and larger volumes
above 1000 microliters should be piped
with electronic devices to save time and
protect your hand and our muscle strain
to organize the viscous fluids in three
categories low viscosity such as
mechanical or edible oil and which is
like 50% glycerol with a dynamic
viscosity less than 200 milli Pascal
second medium viscous fluid such as 86%
glycerol with less than 1000
milliseconds and highly viscous fluids
with a dynamic viscosity above 1000
milliliters per second such as honey
skin cream or 99% glycerol so let us
start with low viscous liquids for these
fluids classic aircraft Russian pilots
can be used and reverse pipetting is
recommended for accurate results
additionally we recommend to pre wet the
tip for more accurate results that means
aspiration and dispensing of the liquid
minimum three times before the actual
liquid volume is transferred to the
sample tube you can compare this with
flushing of the tip if accuracy does not
matter that much in the application
reverse pipe stream is not mandatory
however slow aspiration and dispensing
speed is a must
you
- medium viscous fluids the list can
also be handled with classic pipettes
but reverse pipetting and pre-wetting is
mandatory here also of very slow
aspiration dispensing speed is a must
furthermore you can think about directly
ordering a lower concentration of the
liquid the lower concentrated liquid
would automatically have a low viscosity
additionally you can think about
preheating the liquid to at least room
temperature because the one of the
liquids are usually the less viscous
they get but this is not possible with
some liquids for example enzyme
solutions which would lose activity when
heated so you always have to consider
your sample another trick would be the
pre dilution of the liquid with larger
volumes this could also implement an
additional arrow and less accuracy in
the dilution step so you have to make a
choice there so idly positive
displacement devices should already be
used with medium viscous liquids clear
advantages are that no special carpeting
technique is necessary and the high
concentration of the viscous liquid can
be used pre dilution is not necessary
and if you're using a dispenser or
stepper multi dispensing facilitates the
workflow and is more ergonomic than
pipetting if you want to go all the way
for an electronic dispenser you can also
increase speed of aspiration and
dispensing and protect your hand and arm
muscles from strain
the switch from a medium to a highly
viscous liquid is very smooth so we set
a limit at around 1000 milligram per
second which is slightly below 99%
glycerol here I recommend to switch from
a classic positive displacement tip to a
special tip for highly viscous liquids
which has different properties and
facilities and simply simplifies working
with is highly descriptive goods such as
honey paint or molasses which is very
sticky and viscous at the same time
when it comes to highly viscous liquids
like 99.9% glycerol most positive
displacement devices and to reach a
limit so they cannot take all the risk
of liquor on the market therefore a
special tip for highly viscous liquids
combined with an electronic dispenser is
recommended so strong inspiration and
defending forces are applied to the
positive displacement dispenser and your
arm and hand muscles that is why a
manual device should not be used the
forces strain the arm muscles
excessively and may lead to repetitive
strain injury hence it is important that
the speed of aspiration and dispensing
can be reduced to minimum with an
electronic dispenser to reduce the force
needed and it must have an over strain
protection to prevent the motor further
breakdown
additionally we recommend to also play
with the special tip for highly viscous
liquids like this small air bubbles are
eliminated and the dispensing result is
most accurate the liquid wets the inside
of the tip and the liquid layers flow
more easily while at the same time the
piston wipes the tip from the inside to
guarantee all liquid is delivered
another advantage of using a special tip
for viscous liquids is the reduction of
aspiration and descending forces this
graphic shows that the forces needed can
be reduced up to 79% by using a tip
designed for the script liquids compared
to general positive ii tips this enables
you to use a manual dispenser if you
don't have an electronic device in your
lab or it protects your electronic
device from overstraining because the
motor has less work and the battery is
not stressed that much so it makes sense
to look out for special special devices
for your special applications the
supersize work make it easier for you
and protect your device so that you can
work longer with the device you invested
in so now we are already almost at the
end of the presentation I will give a
short summary now what we just discussed
in the last minute um summing up today's
webinar content this graphic shows when
to use which pipetting tool and
technique so for low and medium viscous
liquids classic air-cushion pipettes
with pre rating and reverse pipetting as
well as a very slow aspiration and
dispensing speed are recommended or even
mandatory when you have the chance to
use a positive displacement device then
do so it is much easier and less
thinking about the liquid end technique
you can use it for all types of this
click words the higher the viscosity
that better it is to use an electronic
device this protects your muscles and
simplifies workflow when using medium or
highly viscous liquids I recommend to
use a special tip for viscous fluids
using this special tip increases
accuracy and precision and leads to
lower aspiration and defending forces
protecting your device and your muscles
okay
so with all these tips I want to end the
main part of the presentation and I
would like to ask you a third question
which is very important for me so I
would like to know how do you rate the
content of this webinar you have four
answers again the first is very good and
useful I will apply the tips and tricks
second is good and useful I will try
some of the tips
the third is okay maybe I will try some
of the tips and the fourth is poor not
useful for my work so I will give you
again in a few seconds the time you need
to answer the questions the question
and
you can already also type in some some
questions you want to ask me for the Q&A
session and very curious on
from what you think about the webinar
and about the questions you will ask in
few seconds I will just wait a little
longer until everybody make a choice
so maybe we will wait five seconds more
than we will go on to the
to the Q&A session
okay
so I think
I think most of you made a choice
already
so I think we can go on
though um you can read more about piping
techniques also with for example
volatile liquids like ethanol or
methanol if this is also an application
your room and at the handling solutions
help page at Eppendorf dot-com slash
private e and here you will also find
many other tips and background
information on pipetting as well as
quizzes and games or actual science
articles so it's just nice to read
through and let us help to optimize your
work and thank you very much for
listening I'm looking forward to an
interesting Q&A session and therefore I
will hand over to Alexis again
thank you dr. hanky for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is
do you have recommendations for
pipetting PE g300 oh so so this is a
very special question I would have to
look exactly at the at the values for PE
g300
because I'm not sure how high the
viscosity is at the moment so I will not
check this I would answer this question
via email in the afterwards because I
have to check what PE g300 is in the
viscosity to give a proper tip I don't
want to say anything wrong at the moment
so um and maybe we can go over to
question 27 because many people ask this
question and they might be interested in
this answer
absolutely where can one buy special
tips and what are they called
okay so thank you for this question and
these special tips they are called visco
tips so especially for viscous liquid
that's the name visco tip you can buy
them as from Eppendorf so you can ask
the sales rep if you visit in your lab
or you can inform yourself on our
website on these visco tips they are
very new we made them just they just
relaunched this year
and another question is also what's the
technology of these tips of these visco
tips for highly viscous liquids so it is
mainly designed so it's a change in the
in the size of the opening and in the
whole structure of the tip there is no
coating there is nothing that might
enter the sample so there you're
absolutely safe they're all tested it is
just a design change to optimize workers
with viscous liquids and flow of viscous
liquids
you
so maybe question number six sounds very
interesting
alrighty which pipette do you recommend
for pipetting egg yolk so yeah I like to
answer this because packaging egg yolk
gives a very special application as well
and you should type it this definitely
with a positive displacement device and
you have to take care that the open with
the tip is wide so that also larger
parts of the egg yolks such as the
umbilical cord can be aspirated yeah I
would also here I would recommend using
the descriptive because it has a wider
opening and then the usual positive
displacement tips so you will much
easier and pipe up the the egg yolk
we are getting so many great questions
dr. Hankey yeah these are great I have
to read through all the questions I
can't even to which to answer because
they are so great and so many so maybe
question 43 is also interesting what
about the low retention tips are they
working well yeah so low retention tips
are just for detergents they are
optimized to piped detergents not for
viscous liquids
I mean detergents also have a higher
viscosity than water but they still have
many other characteristics viscous
liquids flow even slower than detergents
and detergents really stick a lot to the
plastic so actually using lower tension
tips helps a lot when using detergents
but with viscous liquids you will have
exactly the same results as with normal
tips the viscous fluid will not slow
down perfectly and you will have
remaining liquid in the tip so
unfortunately it's a different technique
and you can you should not use low
retention tips with viscous liquids
and
here we have another question 41
so we have what would you recommend us
to use for pipetting liquids that are
foam very difficult to blow out yes
so foamy liquid it's another liquid
cloth then this could liquid but it's an
important question for me liquid has a
very high protein content so this often
happens with cell culture medium for
example or BSA solution and for folding
liquids I would recommend reverse
pipetting because you skip the blowout
and the moment you skip the blowout you
will not get the foamy liquid now you
can also use positive displacement
devices dispensers if you have multiple
samples but if you just want to pipe it
once with air custom pipettes reverse
pipe heading is perfectly
you
we have let me shortly read through some
of the questions
here is one very interesting question we
get pretty often so question number 30
please sure should you set the pipette
above the intended dispensing volume
when pre-wetting the tip actually idly
you pre wet the tick with exactly the
volume you want to pipe it later on so
you don't have to fill the complete tip
with one milliliter if you only wanted
to pipe at 550 for example it's
absolutely fine to use the set volume
and it saves one more step saves more
time than setting the volume from high
truths if it's volume you need so simply
use the volume you want to pipe it in
the end
there's one question this is coming
pretty often so this is just like a
summary of the question many of you
asked if you can have a copy of the
slides or if I can share the
presentation or forward the presentation
unfortunately I am not allowed to share
the presentation but there will be a
recorded version you can listen to it at
any time you want and you can also send
the link of the recorded version to your
colleagues and discuss it and if you
just want the summary or just want to do
the tips and tricks I would recommend to
to just make a screenshot so it's the
easiest but I'm not allowed to share the
complete presentation
[Music]
yes and this presentation will be
available for replay on through December
of 2018 and we have so many good
questions today if anything that we
don't get a chance to answer today we
will be able to to get those answers to
you via the contact information that you
provided at the beginning of this
webinar
yeah okay so
question number 44 is also something
nice
all righty what should the tips be
pre-wet with the viscous liquid or water
yes so since we discussed three wetting
it is like two questions before I chose
this question as well
you should always pre wet the tip with
the liquid you want to pipe it it
doesn't make sense to use water at first
and then switch to glycerol because you
will dilute your sample maybe you will
contaminate your sample so always pre
wet the tip with the liquid you want to
confer
okay so we got two questions number
forty-seven number 48 are quite similar
so you can if you would please read one
of those Alexis absolutely is it
possible to accurately pipette whole
blood yes it is possible to accurately
pipette whole blood because whole blood
is also a little bit viscous so you can
apply the tips I just talked about I
believe you should also use a positive
displacement device because here you're
absolutely sure that you accurately
piped the whole blood and the opening of
the positive displacement device tips
are often a little wider than normal
tips so you can safely transfer all the
cells
so question number 50 is also
interesting
question number 50 is what about
alcohols or DMSO
so alcohol is the different liquid class
than viscous liquids it is a volatile
liquid and for volatile liquids is very
very important it's mandatory to pre wet
the tip you can do a very easy test
yourself if you type up alcohol without
pre-wetting the tip it will immediately
start dripping out of the pipe a tip
because the air-cushion is not saturated
with the liquid and it expands and
pressures out the liquid if you pre wet
the air cushion by aspirating a couple
of times you will saturate the air
insert the tip and you will delay or
even stop the dripping from the piper
tip this depends on the concentration if
you have a 70% ethanol pre-wetting will
be fine and the packet tip will not drip
any more if you are using for example
acetone and pure acetone you will only
delay the dripping because if the
volatility is too high pre-wetting
doesn't work with air-cushion pipettes
anymore if you are using a very highly
concentrated methanol ethanol and
chloroform all these dripping liquids
you should also use positive
displacement devices because of the lack
of the air-cushion you will have no
dripping at all
okay I will I will whip through some
questions again
maybe number 31 is very interesting
all righty thanks for the info we don't
have positive displacement pipette so I
will stick with way
how does wing viscous liquids compared
to positive displacement pipette
okay so um weighing of the samples has
many different influences so if you for
example want to weigh glycerol this
liquid is also hygroscopic so the moment
you bring the glycerol to the balance it
starts saturating with the humidity in
the surrounding air so by time it will
get heavier and heavier so this is very
difficult to calculate them back into
milliliters how much sample you really
have so I don't know which liquid you
weigh in your application but you have
to consider this as a possible problem
and weighing is usually not that
accurate as I tighten with a positive
displacement device because the transfer
and the calculating from grams to
milliliters is always count for errors
and you have to take into account the
density of the liquid the air humidity
the temperature it's almost as
complicated as calibrating a pipette
where you have to consider all these
factors as well if you're doing food
analysis this might be something
different because I know that I don't
know if it's the same in every country
but in Germany it is that if you have
something to eat like Kurt and it stated
in Graham on the packaging you have to
weigh the sample but if you have
something like drinking yogurt which is
stated in milliliter on the packaging
you have to do the analyzers in
milliliters and it is much easier then
to use a positive displacement device
and invest the money into a positive
displacement device then calculating and
taking all these errors into account
while dr. Hankey is going through your
questions I do want to remind all of our
viewers that we will continue dr. hanky
will continue to answer the questions
during the on-demand period so do not
hesitate to throw in a question in there
while you're watching while you re
watching the presentation or if you send
this over to your colleagues and they
watch it as well
yes that's like
[Music]
here we have question number 45
which pipette is recommended for
pipetting semen for semen analysis for
semen analysis I will definitely
recommend to use positive displacement
pipette and I would also recommend using
the disco tip because it has a very wide
opening so you will not destroy this
semen at all and and it has them it's
not it's not only viscous but it also
has a very high amount of proteins and
other nutrients so using a positive
displacement device is definitely
beneficial for testing as semen for
semen analysis
um
[Music]
maybe question
forty-two is also something many might
be interested in all right is it
recommended to wipe the outside of pipet
barrel with a wipe before dispensing
nope not at all so wiping the outside of
the pipe and barrel can lead to some
liquid being pulled out by the tissue
you're using and you risk that your
result is not accurate anymore so only
dive into the liquid as much as you need
so only is human a meters maybe one or
two millimeters deep into the liquid and
while aspirating just follow the liquid
level like this if you don't have that
much additional liquid around the pipe a
barrel and you don't need to wipe it
because wipe is always a risk of losing
some sample
P
and question 51 is also important in the
world
about dilution best direct duration or
cereal
so I would recommend if possible use
direct dilution because you have less
arrows in doing a serial dilution if you
have a very very highly viscous liquid
and direct dilution is very difficult
because they have low volumes then you
must use serial dilution but if possible
which to a positive displacement device
and do a direct dilution so that you
have less error sources
II
[Music]
let me see that question
oh there's still so many questions I
will have to answer many of them via
email this is so great maybe 34
would you please explain more on the
concept of an electronic stepper yes so
an electron stabbers basically the same
as a manual step but it has many more
benefits because you can you can choose
the speed so you have a very very high
rep reducibility and samples if you're
always using the same speed it's it
doesn't depend on your muscles and your
your feelings on the day so one day
you're strong wonder you may be a little
tired so you're slower with an
electronic dispenser or a sonic stepper
it's always the same and also always the
same amongst different people so as many
people have to do the analysis using
electronic stepper guarantees that
everybody is doing it the same way
that's also something especially for
routine labs using electronic devices
and using electronic
positive-displacement devices guarantees
a higher reproduce ability and a lot of
security because often you can you can
program favorite programs
nobody has to change the program
everybody works with the same and you
can also sometimes get in some key lock
so that nobody can change anything this
is a security reason electronic staffers
have many many different advantages most
of them also have different programs and
different modes you can use them for
multi dispensing but you can also use
them just for pipetting so aspirating
once dispensing ones you can use them
for automatic dispensing there you don't
have to use your thumb all the time the
device is simply descending after a
certain time interval which makes life
much easier and some of them also have
like mixing functions and so on so I'm a
great fan of electronic devices and
especially electronics levels make life
much easier so it's worth trying them
ladies and gentlemen this has been an
absolutely fabulous Q&A we have time for
a couple more questions today
okay so I'll show some more
[Music]
so Matt 37
is a syringe suitable for high viscous
fluids
syringe can be suitable for highly
viscous fluids it depends a lot on the
on the design and the shape of the
syringe if it has a very fine opening
like this the ones used for for vaccine
I'm not sure explanation I hope this is
the right word the very thin metal part
on the syringe this is way too small to
correctly aspirate viscous highly
descriptive weight so if you need to use
a syringe or if you only have syringes
in the lab try to use one with wide
opening this will help you escalate in
the liquid and it facilitates your work
if it's not possible to have a syringe
with a wide opening I would not
recommend to use one with a very small
opening because you need to apply a lot
of force to the piston to aspirate the
liquid end and this might be even
dangerous if you pull too much and it
breaks apart you might you know get hurt
or something so take care that the
opening is wide if you want to use
highly viscous liquids
dr. hayslett looks like we will have
time for one more question
one more question okay
question 57
okay dispensing at low volume say one ul
using a twenty UL tip is always a
challenge minor issues like static
humidity tip types make a big difference
it appears low volume pipetting is more
of an art than science do you have any
advice
and yes we have advice and you're right
it is more art than science pipetting
very very small volumes the first thing
you must consider if you need to type of
small volumes always choose the smallest
tip and a smallest possible pipette so
if you need to regularly pipe at one
microliter then please choose a 2.5
micro litre pipette and the according
small tip because this is the problem
with the air-cushion the larger the
air-cushion the more difficult it gets -
espera tend to spend small volumes and
the lower prone to errors the whole
system is so with a very small tip and
be according very small pipette you have
a very small air cushion and this helps
a lot already when pipetting the second
thing is you have to hold the pipette
absolutely vertical while aspiration and
in 45 degree angle with contact to a
vessel wall when dispensing and
pre-wetting the tip with very small
volumes is absolutely mandatory because
during the first aspiration if you don't
do pre-wetting
so much of the liquid already evaporates
into the air cushon that you will never
have an accurate result
so pre-wetting with small tips is even
more important than with larger tips and
if you want to see a video on correct
piping techniques and there you can also
see how to hold the pipette and
everything you can watch on youtube
there's a tutorial video I did it's
called how to pipe it correctly they can
see see the whole positing process and
get some explanations this is the way
you should also deal with small volumes
thank you again dr. hinky and do you
have any final comments for our audience
I thank you so much for all these very
interesting questions there's still so
many left they will be all answered in
the next few days and this is very
important for me to answer every
question so thank you very much for
being so interactive and listening so
well and yeah I'm overwhelmed by with
this audience thank you
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their very very interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of the registration
we would like to say we would like to
thank dr. Hankey for her time today and
her important research we would also
like to thank laborat and our sponsor
Eppendorf for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through December of
2018 laborat to alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
hi